now it is present Trump versus the NFL I
think right I have to say I didn't see
that one coming I didn't see that coming
he took on the entire National Football
League this weekend yeah yeah with his
tweets here present Trump is angry at
NFL players for their silent protest
during the national anthem
he said yeah Trump said silent protests
have no place anywhere outside my
marriage he said this is crazy is this
how crazy it's gotten the national
anthem controversy has even caused a
rift between President Trump and his
longtime friend Tom Brady yes now folks
we should have seen this coming with
Brady because whenever anyone that
beautiful turns 40 Trump loses interest
I no longer love you Tom in an interview
yesterday Treasury secretary Steve
manoosh ins said football players give
up their right to free speech when
they're on the field yes-man gentleman
you know what I'd like to see I'd like
to see Steve minuchin say that to an
actual football player imagine him
talking to a six foot six lineman excuse
me sir not while you're on the clock
yeah you got a zip it here's your
pigskin and off you go
president Trump has distance but he's
going out of his way it's like he's got
a list like Santa who haven't I gotten
to yet right right
who have I not alienated yet yeah well
there's one child and oh right president
Trump has disinvited Golden State
warrior player Steph Curry from visiting
the White House disinvited oh yeah
because no one likes to have curry yeah
he disinvited him yeah not because of
their political differences because
Trump believes curry is from India
I have to take a break from talking
about that guy Anthony Weiner yes
Anthony Anthony Weiner well it's it's
like a crowd that's like he's playing
the oldies wieners back on the charts
Anthony Weiner has been sentenced to
nearly two years two years in jail for
sexting with a teenager yeah
Weiner said come on your honor by the
time I get out she's gonna be 20 what's
keep in mind the crowd was booing his
actions not mine
the crowds like that woman was right not
to stand for this idiot decisions are
looking better and better all the time
this is a weird story people in Florida
of course are slowly recovering from
Hurricane Emma this is true last week
FEMA tweeted out a wrong phone number so
people seeking roof repair found
themselves talking to a phone sex line
yeah probably the phone sex company and
the roof repair company both have the
same slogan fill that hole now
[Applause]
you